hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
today we have another video about soon
da I'm whatever you get the point
basically we're gonna be talking about
all the high level weapons and armor of
the character I've of course thanks to
Ubisoft for giving me early access I had
access to the entire account of the
character on that like 10 because the
account that gave me and I have all the
weapons in our model a lot of you guys
mentioned that I forgot to show the
female armor and the male armor in the
video for your last season so now it's
going to be showing male and female
versions and for the weapons of course
if there is a little star icon next to
the weapon that does mean that that
weapon is a star weapon if you don't
know what a star weapon is it basically
just means that it's more rare to get
out of the crates or at the end of
matches really doesn't provide any like
game bonuses it just means it's a lot
harder to achieve and on November 7th
the day that this goes live I'm going to
be streaming a lot during that first
week because if there's this thing
called these twitch stream drops
basically I'll show the graph on-screen
here if you watch however many hours
that you watch it's going to accumulate
2 XP boosts scavenger crates steel etc
with one hour being one XP boost in 24
hours being 4,000 steel a combat pack 7
days of champion status and two
scavenger grades 24 hours is a lot of
time especially within an entire week so
I'm gonna be trying my hardest to get
all those 24 hours for you guys so I do
apologize if I don't but definitely go
turn in to tune in to my stream is X gin
gy T on Twitch and also it's in the
description if you want to go follow
that after this video goes live so you
can prepare for when the season goes
live we could of course be grinding with
me on your phone on your tablet whatever
you happen to watch yeah as always like
that if you do enjoy guys
let's get into today's video
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]